okay I can't believe this is happening
also I was struggling earlier to start
the stream but now I think it's started
hopefully it's working now I can't
believe what I'm witnessing today was
day three day three of the st. Louis
wrath in the Blitz Carlson has been
having a rough events and it looks like
in order to blow off steam he's playing
Eric Hansen on me chess in one minute
I've played they played 25 games so far
I think this is a current score AK wila
one I forgot this pronounce your name
but good to see you
Aquila thanks for subbing yet again for
five months and Talia in the house if
you're just joining I'm watching Carlson
play chess bras I assume is Eric Hansen
pretty sure Eric plays on this account -
not Oman just got back from tennis
playing with Ray Robson how'd my coconut
water have to stay hydrated tennis was
tiring but watching this watching this
will be slightly more relaxing so
Carlsen winning more games but I mean
this position he's out of exchange some
air pawns are nice but he's up on time
but he has a passed pawn who liked going
in for a sneaky stuff maybe d5 d5 coming
if King g7 d5 so King b7
but then the pawns are falling so trying
to hide in the corner mean the rook the
Queen you'd imagine
that stuff is going to happen and
somehow black is surviving this Queen
night combination is scary three seconds
left just for us what is going on
I'm not taking challenges
sorry bars Maurice okay chests frost
flagged Carlsen having lots of lots of
raiding trying to break 3,000 I was
supposed to get food around now I'll
have to message people that I'm gonna
stay until this match is over in one
moment here wow this pawn storm I have
to text people but I want to watch this
game
so I guess this is how Carlson prepares
for another nine rounds of blitz it's
crazy so crazy look at these pawns I
look away for a moment f6 BAM chess Bay
in the chat what's up chess Bay this
seems like venting he just won st. Louis
spot over yeah he said on the broadcast
today his wishes for the tournament just
to end it and for it to move on while
these pawns are crashing through this
this is a threats just resigns so are we
gonna see Carlson break 3000 because
he's not gonna break 3000 in feed a
blitz or feed a wrap in anytime soon or
feed it classical I think his best
chances me chest bullets Carlsen didn't
challenge me that was me challenging
Carlsen and y'all had sauced with the
sauce to mean like ketchup or barbecue
sauce mmm like losing rating I'll admit
that I stopped by at the beginning of
the tournament today
and then I left after like the first or
second round I worked out I came back
just in time for the tournament wrapping
up I'll be there more tomorrow okay I'll
look away for a moment I'm there already
and an end game people messaging me so
many windows open
to do ok Magnus Oh Magnus is not a lip
on materials equal what's going on here
but black has the only passed pawn on
the board but if it moves and loses c7
ok but he's up on time a little bit is
King c8 king c6 maybe this is nice move
and now king c6 oh but that hangs up hon
so maybe King b5 c5 I like White's
chances here c6 desperate expiration
what's going on
aha
so these double pawns don't provide the
best shelter this might just be a drama
it's a draw Wow good job Erik handsome
I'm 85% sure this is Erik handsome I've
seen him play like in person but I don't
think he's streaming which is why I'm
streaming I'm witnessing history when
was the last time Carlson and Chesbrough
had a bullet match on me chess I mean
this might be a first so the current
score is 21 in half six and a half their
lifetime score is twenty seven and a
half six and a half
so apparently before this match Karl
seven one six in a row and other areas
so weak
oh they played title arenas I'm sure I'm
pretty sure these youtube content of
them playing probably title arenas
probably bullet matches on chess calm
back in the day
a repertories London systems comedian
and kid that's a good combination London
the Scandinavian are actually
surprisingly similar Oh seeing the Sun
my my story I thought I post this on my
story trying to post this on my story
Instagram story yeah - okay another like
intense time scramble what is going on
okay wait looks pretty nice yeah I just
push some baby ole with the rook defense
from behind but blocks about to flag and
like screaming nice finish very nice
finish
ouch
we need predictions in the chat what
does the final score gonna be how many
games are gonna be played there's
already been 29 games will they make it
to a hundred will they make it to 50
it's still before 9 p.m.
st. louis-style next in the next round
of st. Louis and Robin blitz starts at
1:00 p.m. so this could be a long night
okay let's try and follow like a full
game or a full middle game Queen 896 so
nicely for attacking the bishop Wow
just take oh no it's a double attack on
the Queen Bob at the knight defendant 6
no idea what's going on I think things
were just getting treated White has a
bishop hair
a black solid a five block out some say
file actual maybe knife at four
well nice at four not sure what that
does the nights just a good piece on on
e6 works well with the pawns controls
all these squares now d6 is backwards
now both sides kind of dancing around
it's a dance off who can dance better
okay a choose no week rip defense III
played well what just happens lot just
wanted to somehow a breakthrough works
the night depends backwards 96 it should
be easy win ce7 coming and push the pawn
nice keep pushing
push some baby or push X baby okay that
was game 30 we have printed predicting
sixty nine to five
well Eric already has six and a half
I thought you couldn't get to Queens
it's allowed to get to Queens on chess
that's a misconception that you're only
allowed like one Queen the most physical
like chess sets only have one Queen but
technically you can cut up to nine
Queens I had nine Queens once against
Komodo in the Komodo boss rush challenge
was a historic achievements okay this is
a fork but the Kings on e to delayed
ball and cloud
okay White's just winning material oh
this is a pin the pin meeting a fork
knife at five the ping stays rookie to
getting out of the fork Wow very
creative but the Knights are now like
kind of superfluous but maybe that's not
a good thing
this guy's hanging bishops hanging so
Carlsen in trouble down on time equal
pawns but Knights are tricky Knights are
actually trickier than rooks this is
also tricky that was a free pawn so this
is just desperation for whites should be
a technical win I mean if I had this
position as black I would be shaking
about to defeat the world champion rook
c3 doesn't even hang a rook that was
nice did Carlsen rage quit no he didn't
defense key what's up Mariinsky welcome
back I saw you commenting on my previous
stream on the US chess Channel
why do you think Magnus is not doing
well and Grantchester I mean when it
comes to rapid and blitz it comes down
to a lot of mental form it just seems
like he's he's off for him something's
clearly wrong I don't know what the
causes
it seemed like confidence issues are are
affecting him and that's what he said in
interview today so again I look away for
a moment and what's happening there is
obstacle our bishops pawns are equal
white going for some attack I like the
way that at chess for his plan in winsy
seven
now this kena feels very unsafe very
unsafe but how does white break through
as a bishop defends from a distance mean
he said it himself that confidence was
affecting him he was second-guessing
himself even today like his game against
Aronian where he won this Queen versus
rook ending he got to a position which
was just like it was a type of position
I could convert when I was like eight
years old like these classic what must
new endgame position and he was he was
really hesitating ooh he lost
Queenie Yeats white broke through ouch
it's only 300 people who's for okay 415
people watching on me chess I'm curious
I'm watching a game what happens if I
click this what would happen
do I even it there does I know like
during a game you can voice chat with
your opponents Joanna tries what's up
Joanna good to see you in the checks
okay I know there's conversation between
streaming just Congress isn't a chess
yeah I mean it's kind of spread out
there's probably more like popular
streamers streaming on chess calm they
have so many more events
and many sources for streamers but I
guess it's a matter of taste
ice cream on both both have their pros
and cons before okay so why targeting
the b-pawn now this looks like very nice
structure for like Boston playing some
nice positional chests this Bishop whoa
lock just resigned no flights it was
equal no boy was up a pawn yeah what was
doing well at a poun - McCarroll con a
solid position pebble-sized will see
this maneuver probably NEA 5 yeah and
you swing this it looks like is that
that free pawn any fives kind of the
targets White has no time to take it
some point I would like to see my Chi 6
and just attack on the Kings side
hey none juice thanks for subbing for
two months appreciate that
so looks like Magnus is out playing Eric
again up to pawns Eric just resigns so
now he was slowly trying to work his way
up a three the Pescador I remember
seeing a walk on this it was written by
PES gadot it's a tricky opening white
does weird stuff yes what does b6f for
such creative play this feels like
something Korea would do not sure if
this is good look White has like two
half flopping files guess that's the
benefit of losing pawns for doubling
pawns boy has a bishop here f5 now
there's really no like safe place for
the black king maybe the center is the
safest place Alec windy three maybe some
idea
huger to trying to hide in the corner or
cry in the corner also waits fantasizing
about League Rookie 7 but the pawn is on
c5 okay so at some point wait should win
back c3 what's going on here I don't lay
Magnus's position looks very very
delicate block has a lot of pressure
Queen h3 coming good move attacking the
rook some slight skewer whoa look at
this move sacking the exchange bike
using all the pieces but man I'm just
getting some counter plays Queen h3
there's this and then there's rook a8
meeting
Wow and chess Hall only has like 10
seconds Bishop g3 what's Bishop g3 this
is just over easy man what a finish some
massive counter punching like Czeslaw
was just throwing punch after punch and
all of a sudden magnets just like
knocked him out of nowhere
okay normal um no not normal opening
elephants what do I call this elephant
defense alpha gambits something weird in
there they're getting some queenless
middlegame
Oh sighs should win back each other's
epon seems slightly preferable for black
just more developments
maybe Knights mm not even 94 just wings
of pong yeah I'm gonna try and catch
more openings it's hard to look back and
forth between the chats and the game and
during my coconut water the bamboo stick
andit's yeah the chad is trying to be as
entertaining games so box of upon this
should be a position Nagas wins early 90
98 percent of the time unless he mouse
slips or flags he's a long time g5 it's
got some g5 emotes person f6 bam emotes
can you do a video on Magnus's bullet
games or bullet openings I'm doing a
stream on his bullet games
hopefully that counts for something so
now it's a race between the spawn and
these pawns looks like blacks should be
faster just take ooh
96 is nice now just push yeah and this
white would like to come from behind
that there's no square just take the
free rug
good job so that's a than half twenty
seven and a half we have up kirats we
have a normal opening kind of sort of
what does this old Indian dfd six with
early key five it has a solid reputation
I think it's got four bullets a White
has a nagging edge just a bit more space
easy southern trading a pair of knights
Carlsen doing Carlsen things should be
two probably nine of four at some points
get that repair yeah take the rook and
get the bishop hair looks Pleasant takes
for the way a for Grandmaster move very
typical pawn break c4 explosive probably
just losing upon ya the bishop defends
this pawn rook b8 Bishop c4 will defend
everything Johanna wants to see them
play full like crazy house how do you
funny I don't think it's gonna happen
though I'd be cool though
yeah the last time I streamed watching
Magnus played bullets was in February I
was in Portugal I was in Lisbon and I
was staying at an Arab uni and he was
playing some match on the chest against
the English Chicago and there was some
double adoption not sure if I ever put
that on YouTube yeah there's 461 people
watch them for okay there's a lot of
spectators HOH people can't see but now
people can kind of see spectators yeah
this is kind of out of the blue King
Gupta what's up king gupta it's a mod
king gupta should be a VIP VIP doesn't
usually join the action but today is a
special day
who is Oh who's playing I read that as
who's playing against chess brah
okay for those who don't know this is
Magnus Carlsen and this is I believe
Eric Hansen I think it's been confirms
not sure though and I'm pretty sure okay
if I'm not mistaken Eric should be in
town at some points at the same time
Magnus is in town so maybe in the near
future there will be an over the board
rematch interesting okay Jess pace says
that chess bras on me chess is always
handsome just I'll trust chess beyond
that so Magnus in trouble Magnus and
lots of trouble these clowns are fast
and furious but Magnus is up on time
it's a nice move I was like a fork
skewer just move Bishop f3 and flag on
just add blue just add blue shall i time
out just add blue
just a blue let's keep it child
child-friendly that's okay just a blue
is an 11-month subscriber and the 50 sub
gifter what is wait what was this
opening what what okay this is like a
Marshall yeah but what is f3
well this a 5 what is d5 that's real
life okay he played g5 so he should win
he wants to do this and g6 someday
though black wants to meet someday on e
- okay you played g6 maybe a bit
prematurely each v just sac everything
it might be mates also all four Center
squares are occupied Law Center action
happening
it's just gives me a headache h5 he just
wants to meet him boy he has to move
zero it's almost meet what is Knight
takes e4 you two looks very delicate ooh
the Queen moves from faraway places this
is just over maybe King f7 last try
because each is a meeting idea why do
you resign Queen d7 this Queenie six
maybe yeah that's probably over my
background looks blurry I'm using a
green screen so hopefully it's not like
it's supposed to be transparent not
blurry
wait what just happened
ooh okay Magnus hung a thing on g6 and
then proceeded to lose exchange but he
has a knife a knife or he has a bishop
pair he has a pin a lot of compensation
rook f8 coming and just take that rook
t8 nice move it's gonna win the Queen
well I will have two rooks for the Queen
maybe 9h three nice uh there will be a
fork oh maybe not Bishop g8 do it well
Kings on g5 what is going on the king is
surprisingly safe on g5 it can't be
checks along file or ring or it can oh
there is f4 in the air
ouch chess browse wins another game it's
nine and a half to thirty and a half
crazy if you can't keep up how are us
peasants supposed to yeah we're all
peasants compared to these people even
though I have a plus score against
Magnus okay this is actually a
reasonably like positional game nothing
too crazy yet except the pawn push in
the Queen mouth
a4 always play king b1 or not Bishop c3
I don't know if he wants to take the a
pawn now f5 a counterpunch we need to
align it with the king take the hook I
see four outposts some interesting law
information looks like one of those like
hook things what looks like a plunger 96
wait this is just over just got
destroyed there our adoptions still a
thing I guess everything there is a
closed adoption one two three four five
six seven seven in row I think is a max
number of games one how did Rosen find
out about this
I have my sources what is this what is
Kim G - delayed reflected bong cloud 93
is a threat oh but he saw it
d5 nice move all black wants to do is
open the center and checkmate whites
yeah Lots succeeded Center is now open
riffle Sunday comes in d8 the bishops
hanging be choose hanging rook d8 nice
move so the King has made kind of a
journey and it's sure run and hide and
now it's just Queen and Bishop for his
Queen and Knights the black one a pawn
so it's four on three maybe just trade
everything okay this should be easy win
for Magnus he's up about 14 seconds yeah
Jasper just resigns ruff is that it game
over what to do
Oh next game let's follow the English
opening kingside fianchetto they're
playing a main line I think this is a
main line yeah this looks kind of normal
the bishop looks weird on d6 actually
play c6 probably at some point my FF v
d6 what am I
so positional so it has a bishop hair
and better structure will have a double
theme kettle very soon maybe Queen D for
coming just meets f6 BAM d7 is kind of
weak if you rook C D and when does it
move that's also know that's a nice move
and now White has control over at both
files black has pressure against efore
lots of things targeting efore black has
four attackers and a
in what does way to e5 nice move take
whoo so many counter punches Oh
but the bishop defends backwards free
Queen Bishop takes t5 wanna move take
and then taking them defend and you win
because you're up a bishop
what a combination I wasn't seen and
there's no others trick that was a last
trick black resigns what a game I was
insane he's after Queen I thought he'd
blundered at me you know exactly what he
was doing mm-hmm
we have a Spanish we have a weird
Spanish 9500 takes f7 is a really
interesting move after 9:00 at 595 what
is f6 Magnus Carlsen probably doesn't
listen to men Feingold the truth hurts
so why it was threatening this rock
defended f5 still threatening us this
looks really ugly for black Queen h5
it's just winning chess fraud is in
shock doesn't even play Queen h5 King g7
King is running actually the Queen side
is pretty safe you can just like call
the luck with the Queen side pieces 96
96 was that waste you sack and
everything black has such nice structure
it's like drops white sacking more stuff
all for g7 oho takes takes Queen d6 okay
or this and yeah blacks just winning g2
what a game what a game another game
thirty four and a half to nine and a
half how many people let's get like a
prediction for the number of games
they're gonna play they've already
played 44 games will they play more than
50 games probably but will they play
more than hundred mouths I'm thinking
about 75
I wouldn't be surprised if they play
over 100 that would be crazy people sing
a wide range of numbers hello took over
welcome back if you're just joining
we're watching Carlson against Eric
Hanson it would be sad though this is a
last game was this match set up I have
no idea I mean I found out about it when
they were about 20 games in I think
somewhere around there I mean night
versus Bishop both have like good monger
pieces what's my stream title die mess
up the stream title what I do I had a
slight problem starting my stream so I
may have goofed things up oh this is
fine Magnus Carlsen wrist chest bra I
think that's fine yeah Eric is is no
joke in in bullets like he's pretty good
so nine and a half is got a good score
against Magnus I would say and neither
of them are streaming it's hard to
stream bullets and keep the quality up
not obvious who Magnus I mean most
people should know who magnus carlsen is
maybe there's more people who don't know
who chest fries if you're watching chess
on Twitch
you should know who both people are I
look away for another moment
looks like Jasper was just crashing what
is this
there's a d6 coming game over means two
rooks for a queen but who 94
are you for defending this but threaten
just hanging made in one was rough yeah
this is a slightly surprised stream so I
was planning to eat I'm hungry
maybe I should get delivery what did you
I can't remember if there's ever been a
time where Magnus is just like done this
during a tournament now it is like a
rapid blitz tournaments but Sinquefield
Cup is starting in a few days he's just
trying to blow off steam with more chest
you know the tilt is real yeah I'm in
st. Louis I stopped by today at the
Chess Club
I'll be at some field cup if you're
gonna be in st. Louis let me know feel
free to stop by and say hi no there's
gonna be a lot of people visiting should
be a fun event this pawn is crossing the
Red Sea ship d7 blockade Bishop g4
trying to remove the blockade so the
Queen defends at five I find this a bit
weakening though Bishop g4 condom maybe
ooh Queen f7 threatening the bishop and
threatening bishop d5 the bishops just
trapped
oh and the other bishop is hanging too
so we have a modern very modern 21st
century chess each five not a bad
opening for bullets like black just does
a set of doublethink Eddowes wishes
pawns and arguably arguably both bishops
are good here so come the pawn chain
complement suspicion
I think the bishop and pawns work
together to control a lot of center
squares Qasim is interesting maybe white
will play G Florida more focus is in the
center maybe a bite you Castle what does
a knight be - probably preparing this
this bishops kind of sad it's just
staring at a very solid con Shane
I'd have to prefer white here a bishop a
six now the bishops happy probably King
f2 so things got traded okay now I have
to prefer black the rook is active as
pawns hanging not sure why he didn't
take it now he takes it ooh nice e5
prevents 47 the rookie seventh pawns
gonna fall ah but there's check now that
for takes a bishop and black will be out
material that's nice and then the rook
should come back to d4 just take the
bishop or gay for rook d4 and then you
can even save the pawn with a four in
metals yeah just brought just resins can
you watch the match from Eric's
perspective wait which Eric because I'm
watching the match from my own
perspective do you want me to flip the
board boards flips this is okay now
we're gonna see
well it's like to get destroyed by
Magnus assuming Magnus will destroy
again I really don't like this position
for lack just a structure so ugly the
Knights are out of play
White's pieces are so happy a black
trying to be like creative trying to
confuse whites mmm this is a fork the
nights hanging rook c2 nice move with a
counter punch but this is still hanging
that was hanging everything's hanging 96
check more stuff is falling what's going
on
take c6 what just happened here's that
material black is not material a4 get
rookie 7 rook b6 b7 just check the
kingdom or take a bishop nice move I
could still up a pawn after all the
dusts feel like the dust never never
said it all never settles um what what
was in 97 I was expecting rook e8 so now
white is up a piece a black is getting
weird counterplay the blacks up on time
Knight e3 will their move whoo rook e1
coming okay I don't think Magnus will be
quick enough black is off upon two easy
win Wow
so Jasper Oz one that that's how it
feels to beat Magnus what a game thought
Magnus was gonna win that one but he
didn't that's crazy
well what is this a sack that work night
see 795 want to move because the Queen
Dixie six hours a night c7 check the
nights are coordinating well here free
Brooke we Nix G 2 F 1 we would counter
play well I could have taken that but I
like night 95 focusing on activity this
is kind of a fork and I'd still defend
each other this nights kind of stuck
though free pawn again I have no idea
what's going on this is so hard to
follow
ok this nights gonna escape probably
lock trying to clean up on why trying to
do stuff with the pieces locks up apiece
no bucks down the exchange now this is
gonna lose again it's gonna be two in a
row for chest bra McQuaid's pieces are
so beautiful but Jasper are low on time
it should be an interesting finish a g6
is kind of a fork ship c6 nice move mmm
see five world Bishop e7 winning back
material magma still has a passed pawn
yeah it's all about trying to flag
whites I think you're down on material
but you're up on time calls for a dirty
flag love HS thanks for stopping by and
thanks for stopping by the US chest
commentary